éric fricot bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors les
soignants qui manifestent à nouveau 15
jours après une mobilisation qui a vu
qu'ils avaient vu quelque cent mille
personnes dans plus de 200 villes
manifester est-ce qu'il faut battre le
fer tant qu'il est chaud vous attendent
et une mobilisation massive de nouveau
aujourd'hui
tout à fait oui elle le sera toute façon
même si on a conscience que dans les
hôpitaux c'est très difficile et très
compliqué d'aller manifester dans la rue
dans les assignations sont à des auteurs
lucie nan mais non dans le personnel est
en colère le personnel est en détresse
la dernière manifestation l'a prouvé on
a réussi à associer les pour redescendre
au maximum dans la rue et non là c'est
très très très compliqué dans les
hôpitaux mais on y arrivera il faut
absolument que le gouvernement comprenne
que oui on a été nous ont mis son reste
à turin c'est eux qui nous ont misé sur
une seringue qui des soirées pied
comment héroïque
nous on demande juste avoir des salaires
ça fait trop longtemps que nos salaires
sont violés ses envies dans les
conditions qui sont limite la descente
alors ça peut être choquer certains mais
croyez-moi nos revendications sont
toujours très simple c'est juste 300
euros 400 euros de rattrapages et après
on veut les salaires minimum à hauteur
de 1700 euros
et c'est pas 300 millions comme vous le
dénonciez dans votre dans votre
générique qui feront la différence avec
les 6 milliards les 300 millions en plus
ont été donnés étaient proposées pour le
corps médical pour les internes et pour
le corps médical
certainement pas pour les autres
personnels hospitaliers donc oui 6
milliards on est très très loin du
compte d'autant plus que si on voyait
remettre un petit clip de l'hospitalier
qui a actuellement la maladie roues
égales autres on a de nouveau des
clusters en france donc on est on aura
besoin du personnel soignant et
personnel soignant doit être valorisée à
hauteur de l'effort mais considérable
et qui a été entrepris pendant ces trois
mois alors justement la dernière
manifestation on a vu un qui a été
émaillée de certaines violences il y a
aussi des personnes qui ne faisaient pas
partie du corps hospitalier qui
manifestaient donc est ce que vous avez
eu l'impression que voilà la
manifestation finalement de la semaine
dernière vous a été volée c'est pour
cela que vous redescendez à nouveau
aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est nous on n'en
veut effectivement à ce gouvernement qui
a laissé rentrer ces casseurs et qui ont
une mode d'expression qui n'est pas du
tout celle des soignants voilà nous on
fonctionne pas comme ça en font de cette
page dans cette danse et violence là il
ya une stratégie derrière c'est clair on
nous a laissés avec d'être noyautés par
ces gens là ils sont venus ils ont voilà
encore une fois ils ont exprimé leur
mécontentement à leur manière à la façon
de faire qui est pas forcément la note
et mais qui est plutôt qu'un autre
on a vu il ya eu des collègues une
collègue infirmière mais d'autres
collègues ont été bousculés qui ont
réagi par ces violences qui étaient
présentes sur le terrain c'est
déplorable mais on est solidaire avec
tous les personnels qu'on était non
seulement violenté et malheureusement et
ont mis aussi écran ont véhiculé une
image qui est pas forcément céder soit
un an après c'est pas eux c'est pas
parce que il ya eu cette manifestation
avec les gaz lacrymogènes et avec des
casseurs que l'on redescend dans la rue
non on a bien compris de faire descendre
dans la rue en mettant un coup de
pression à ce gouvernement avec je
n'arrête pas de le dire qu'il est de
plus en plus craintifs
monsieur vers ans est arrivé avec une
enveloppe de 6 milliards il va falloir
doubler cet angle on doit faire des
monsieurs 20 qui on l'a annoncé il y
aura des augmentations significatives
il y aura des vrais plans d'action pour
l'hôpital public ben oui fait le voilà
il faut donner les moyens l'hôpital
public
il a rempli sa mission on a vu elle
était toute l'importance de l'hôpital
public face à cette pandémie
on l'a prouvé l'hôpital public doit
rentrer dans la constitution française
la andreu de nouveau être confrontés
malheureusement le forte probabilité
qu'on soit autour de nouveau
on était à la pandémie puisqu'on voit
qu'il ya des clusters qui sont en train
de flamber partout sur toute la france
donc on a besoin des personnels
soignants mais quelle sera la motivation
et l'envié de tous ces personnels
soignants de repartir entre guillemets
au combat face à cette pandémie
alors que jusqu'à présent on nous donne
que des bâtons pour nous faire taper
dessus donc croyez moi les personnels
hormis la culture judéo chrétienne ils
vont pas tendre la joue gauche pour
prendre une gifle sur cette joue là donc
non nous on veut des moyens on veut être
reconnu à d'autres juste valeur on a
fait on n'a pas été relié qu'on a fait
juste notre boulot de soignants voilà
c'est tout ce qu'on nous a demandé de
faire on l'a fait avec nos qualités et
nos capacités et nos valeurs maintenant
il faut qu'ils aient de l'argent
derrière il faut qu'on reste tous les
salaires encore une fois le salaire ses
nerfs de guerre parce que c'est ce
salaire qui va faire venir des jeunes en
sortie d'école et et qui va qui feront
d'eux des nouveaux collègues
là pour l'instant si on ne les paye pas
à la hauteur ces gens là ces symptômes
qui vont sortir l'école ils ne viendront
pas épouser la carrière de personnel
soignant ou de personnels hospitaliers
parce que c'est vrai qu'on focalise sur
le personnel soignant mais croyez moi
dans les hôpitaux
il ya aussi le personnel administratif
qui a fait un boulot considérable
il ya aussi le personnel ouvrier qui a
fait un boulot mais dantesques et il ya
toutes ces tous ces corps de métiers qui
sont invisibles et qui ont permis à
l'hôpital public de le tenir et qui ont
épaulé les personnels soignants pour
faire face à cette pandémie
merci beaucoup eric tricot d'avoir réagi
sur notre antenne je rappelle que vous
êtes infirmier anesthésiste à l'hôpital
henri mondor syndicat sud-santé merci